pour le fermier info santé appuyés sur
l'a1
après deux heures d'attenté nous avons
finalement réussi à obtenir la ligne
mais à notre grande surprise ce n'était
pas une infirmière d'info-santé au bout
du fil
oui bonjour ce que je te laisse vous
sentez vous attend mais on a un problème
avec le réseau est aujourd'hui et je
suis que ça fait longtemps que vous
attendez le par plusieurs personnes
notre appel ensuite été transférée info
santé mais la communication a coupé
retour à la case départ le ministère de
la santé confirme que son système
téléphonique éprouvent des difficultés
techniques et que des mesures seront
mises en place pour améliorer la
situation
je pense que c'est navrant parce qu'on a
vraiment besoin d'un service
téléphonique pour rassurer la clientèle
rassurer les patients et surtout ne pas
faire que des patients se rendent à
l'urgence pour avoir un dépistage par
exemple info-santé comptes sont
infirmières pour répondre au téléphone
partout dans la province elles sont
débordés par le volume d'appels beaucoup
plus important qu'à l'habitude
des citoyens ont dit attendre plus d'une
heure trente qui étendent attentes en ce
moment d'autres citoyens ont dit avoir
dû appeler deux trois quatre fois avant
de finalement pour rejoindre quelqu'un à
partir d'aujourd'hui le service va être
améliorée on va ajouter 20 postes
graduellement on fait un appel à tous
pour que toutes les infirmières qui
veulent nous donner des arts fo santé
nous appelle les infirmières enceintes à
la retraite ou en travaux légers sont
priés de se manifester pour donner un
coup de pouce à leurs collègues du étant
un ici olivier bascharage au canada
montréal